from Jim Henson George Lucas and Monty
Python's Terry Jones comes a kids movie
just as weird as you'd expect from Jim
Henson George Lucas and Monty Python's
Terry Jones labyrinth
get ready for the 1980s cult classic
that we never thought we'd make an
honest trailer for but decided to do so
we could talk about how awesome David
Bowie was I've brought you okay so
forget the meandering plot and soso
acting because David Bowie
steals every scene he's in as jerath the
goblin king a magical creature that can
only be described as David Bowie just
love me do as I say and I will be your
name who will have you spellbound by his
magic tricks dancing and his Major Tom
and by the hypnotic way he pronounces
baby a cat about the baby and baby says
baby screaming baby in a performance so
iconic you won't even care he's playing
a kidnapper with the hots for a 16 year
old Jennifer Connelly stars as the
teenager who made you feel funny in 1986
and grew into the adult that made you
really uncomfortable in the year 2000
when she sacrifices her baby brother to
a goblin just to get out of babysitting
he'll be whisked away to this model
castle and will go inside the mind of a
young girl navigating a maze full of
danger fluids and sexual confusion over
an older male authority figure
so basically puberty before Andy Serkis
played make-believe in a high-tech
wetsuit Jim Henson played make-believe
by stuffing dwarves in the uncomfortable
vinyl bobble heads in this 90-minute
tour of the Muppet master sheer
creativity that's so muffiny even its
editors name is
Rober full of amazing creatures
groundbreaking visuals and bark jokes
lots and lots of fart jokes sing along
with all the classic labyrinth songs you
love and totally remember like magic
dance and the red puppet fire song thing
or nope that's not familiar I don't even
remember that one okay it's basically
just magic dance listen the dude was
prolific they can't all be Ziggy
Stardust so experience a film up there
with a neverending story and The Goonies
as a classic 80s movie that isn't quite
as good as you remember which completely
bombed at the box office as you know
what who cares
cuz David Bowie is [ __ ] awesome that
guy could do whatever he wanted to me in
his magic goblin castle and starring
glam doll of David Bowie's hand double
not a girl not yet a woman Bernie
Sanders Rocket Raccoon The Eyes Wide
Shut orgy Harry Knowles Java jr. and
baby Waldo The Maze Runner oh man
even by puppet standards these things
are really creepy those are definitely
real tears be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers or you'll do what
exactly hit me with that fish-like rap
doors hammer by the sons of war van you
shall be avenged turn to page 394
now I have a machine gun ho ho Oh mr.
Potter our new celebrity I'm going to
count to three
there won't be a four give me the code
Loxley I'm gonna cut your heart out with
a spoon Happy Trails Hans